The joe rogan experience.
It's instant trauma.
I mean,
I have mental illness.
I have a cousin who is paranoid schizophrenia.
All right.
And my dad would tell me,
but he's my,
I don't know how the fucking second remove shit works is my father's first
cousin.
Okay.
Still alive.
Dude.
Smoked a carton of cigarettes in three days.
Whoa.
I mean,
we have no idea how he's ever a throat fucking left.
But he was really fucking,
he was a black belt in karate.
He was great at Lacrosse.
He had Hopkins,
Syracuse,
big schools looking at him and then he'll tell you he started doing drugs and he
went fucking the Syd Barrett route and he just went off the fucking deep end.
And he's permanent disability,
diagnosed paranoid schizophrenia.
And um,
you know,
he's,
we all love him but,
and he's fucking hilarious.
Like he'll play with it because sometimes he's on his meds and you can tell
you're like,
oh,
you're dialing in right now.
Start telling family secrets.
I'm like,
don't listen to him.
Like not an option right now is when you listen to them.
I can see it in their eyes.
The other times when he's off looking over here like that,
you don't know.
But we would go like he had an apartment and I would go visit them from time to
time and he had poetry and sayings and stuff written all over the wall.
And I'm like,
what is this?
And he's like,
well at night when I'm home alone to doctors come in through my window,
they drop liquid acid in my ears and they knock me out and then they start
taking samples of my body and after they leave,
the love of my life comes and I can't communicate with her.
So this is how I communicate with are these are there for when she comes in to
speak for me and I'm like,
Whoa,
whoa.
So his windows are nailed shut to keep the doctors out and like how's that work?
And he's like,
it's not.
So one day I'm over there and he's watching TV with the volume all the way down
and the radio up and that's how he's watching this program.
And I'm telling you,
it started to fucking make sense.
I was like,
I gotta get the fuck out.
I gotta get Outta here.
Gary,
sorry,
I'm out of here on this.
There's a disease that,
um,
I'm trying to remember the name of it,
but it,
it basically is when people are around schizophrenia x for too long,
they develop schizophrenia themselves.
Really?
Yeah.
There's some people who are sympathetic to it,
to the point where,
God,
I want to say,
I want to say it's called Allah phrenia.
There's,
there's a some sort of a disease that occasionally infects people or,
or gets people that visit people in the hospital that are schizophrenia.
So someone will come,
like family member will come visit you and they will get diagnosed and they will
get admitted themselves and know hat they'll actually get it.
They get it.
I don't know like to what stage,
but apparently it is an,
it's a potential issue for some people because like,
look,
have you ever been hypnotized?
No.
I thought it was horse shit to my friend Vinny shoreman,
who is a sports hypnotist who works for a lot of fighters.
He hypnotized me.
I'm like,
Whoa,
this is real.
It just puts you in a very bizarre stay feel that state.
Yes,
you're there,
you're awake,
you're conscious,
but you're in a strange state.
It's almost feel something.
Yeah.
I like,
you're like,
like you're in a tube of consciousness or something,
like you're in a womb.
It's very,
very interesting.
But I'm listening to him and he's a friend.
I trust him.
He's a great guy.
So it wasn't weird about it.
So I was like,
Oh yeah,
you could do it.
God,
let's see.
Let's see what happens.
I was Kinda skeptical.
I was like,
this is horseshit.
But I've been to,
have your been to one of those hypnotist comedy shows?
No.
My friend Frank Santos,
he was a guy who,
uh,
he's passed away,
but he was a big time comedy hypnotist guy in Boston and in Rhode Island and he
had a show and he,
I saw his show man.
He used to do like one night a week it stitches and one night a week at Nick's
comedy stop.
And Dude,
we would go down there on days off just to watch.
It was crazy.
He would take people out of the audience like who wants to be able to touch and
he had a weird way of talking and who want to be hitting ties.
You want to be hypnotized.
Fun of con.
It was like a around jolly fellow real friendly glasses,
you know,
like totally unassuming.
You didn't think you'd,
and then he would bring these people on stage and he would just be able to take
sweetie,
you're going to go under,
you're gonna,
you're gonna fall asleep.
You're gonna fall asleep.
When I snap my fingers,
you're going to thank you.
Our Sally fields at right next to you is Burt Reynolds
and he would see these people and they really,
they were like smokey.
We got to get away from the police.
Like they really believed he had this one guy.
He told her they would,
they would actually speak like that person.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
They didn't know what they were out of the mind.
This one guy,
he told the guy,
this was the 80s he told the guy that the guy was having sex with Madonna.
He's like underneath you as Madonna and you're squeezing her booties.
You're booby her boobies and she's naked and you're about to have sex with her.
You're going to have sex,
you're having sex with her right now.
And the guy had an orgasm on the stage.
He's,
he's sitting there on the stage.
He's like,
ah,
and the audiences,
I'm talking people,
I fall it out of their fucking chairs crying,
laughing,
you couldn't,
but it was real man.
And some people,
it wasn't real.
Like some people would look at him and you go,
hey,
hey buddy.
Hey Buddy,
look at me.
Look at me.
You're not under good.
Come on.
Come off and say this guy was like,
ah.
And the guy would come up to say he would know who was under,
who wasn't under this guy was a man.
He would work with people who are trying to quit smoking and you're trying to
quit gambling,
smoking thing,
gambling,
booze.
They can,
apparently they can do it with a lot of different things with it,
but it,
smoking is a big one.
But he,
he just could do it to some people.
And I'm telling you quick,
he would do it and there's fucking 300 people in the room,
but he would be like,
I'm going to cut my fingers from the count of three.
You're in the car and the police are chasing you.
One,
two,
three.
What are you doing now?
I'm in the car.
The cops are chasing me.
And it was just instant man.
I mean it was,
it was some people,
they just fall into these states of mind and open to suggestions.
Some people can be hypnotized.
And this is why some people I think join cults,
like I'm watching this new,
the Netflix program.
Wild wild country.
Yeah.
Fucking crazy.
Crazy.
But some people I think are more susceptible to suggestion and more susceptible
to cults.
And I think that is,
that's what's happening.
I think that's what's happening with,
with this Allah phrenia thing.
If that's what it's called.
Um,
I might be remembering that incorrectly,
but this,
this thing that being around his schizophrenia person,
like whatever weird error they're brain is making your,
your brain tunes into that air and you start going crazy too.
As soon as that shit made sense.
Miles like I gotta get the fuck out of here cause he's done.
He's harmless.
He's never heard anyone,
but he still,
you know,
these days he's what he's prop guy.
He's probably in his sixties,
nothing
shape.
But back then when he still knew of martial arts,
oh he was stage a man who was dangerous,
but he never hurt anybody,
but he knew how to.
And um,
so one day there's eastern avenue in Baltimore's,
for lack of a better term,
the Ventura Boulevard of Baltimore shops everywhere and everything.
And there was this one woman,
the had cut his hair one time and for him,
excuse me,
to touch his head,
was a big deal for him.
This.
So he immediately fell in love with this lady.
Her name was Carissa.
So he went home and got his guitar.
And the thing about this guitar,
like this dude would pawn his bed,
his guitar,
everything.
But that guitar was always out of tune.
Exactly the same way.
Do you understand what I'm saying?
Does that make sense?
Okay.
So always fucked up,
but always consistently fucked up every guitar he had.
That's how he tuned it.
That's how he heard it.
Oh Wow.
So he writes her,
he writes her a love song and he wants to go up to her shop and now sing it for
her.
So he goes up and he stands out in front of the shop and he's gets her
attention.
He's got his guitar and he's gone.
It starts off where he goes.
He goes,
Chris,
I love you and Baltimore accents.
Current name's Karissa.
But he says,
Chris,
Okay Chris,
I love you Chris.
I need you.
Then he goes,
Chris had all died because of Chris at all crack cause I to die Chris at all.
And she's freaking out like,
what the fuck?
Yeah,
like your eyes.
So they call the police,
he gets arrested.
Oh No.
And he doesn't understand why he's arrested in his mind.
What did I do wrong?
I just wrote a beautiful song for someone I care about and I wanted to share it
with her.
So my cousins,
all of us were like,
we gotta go to court and watch this.
This is going to offend because he's got,
he's got to go to court.
So they bring them out from tobacco.
Oh No.
And he stands up and it's a,
it's a female judge and my,
his mom,
my aunt Margaret and my great aunt,
my grandma's sister,
but extended family big time and we're all there watching and the judge says ask
the girl her side of things and she's like,
well this happened.
And he's like,
she's like,
would you like to speak on your behalf?
And like I just don't understand what I did wrong.
I wrote a song for someone I care about and I just wanted to share it and she's
like,
would you mind sharing some of the lyrics of,
we're all like,
oh shit.
And He fucking Chris,
I love you Chris.
I need you crystal all crack cause I want to die.
She goes,
okay,
that's enough.
That's enough.
And then they're about to let him go because they understand I'm going to put a
restraining order.
He's under supervision,
but they're about to let them go.
And she goes,
oh wait a second.
Oh,
there's a,
there's still an open charge here on the books,
so we're gonna have to take you back to it.
He starts losing his shit.
Like what?
Maya?
Marguerite stands up and to a judge,
she goes,
Hun,
we dropped those charges.
Everyone calls,
people hunt in Baltimore.
She goes,
Hun,
we dropped those charges.
That lady said,
first of all,
you don't call me Hud.
I am a judge.
You address me as your honor.
We're all like,
I have augury got scolded by the judge and they fucking took him back and he was
screaming going on.
They put,
uh,
the family put a charge on him.
Yeah,
he had,
he would do things like,
he would show up to their place in a cab demand.
They pay for it.
They didn't,
he throw a brick through the window.
So they had a
head of a resident for that Jesus Christ.
And they really did drop the charges,
but it was just a clerical error that never made it to the paperwork.
And she's like,
I got to do what I gotta do.
We're taking you back today.
And he was,
they were pulling it back and he was gone nuts.
Oh my God.
Yes.
It ended up that fucking haircut and he would say shit to him.
He would swear to me that nurses would give him head in the hospital.
He would and,
and,
and part of the time,
I don't know,
but one that really blew my mind was um,
he had to scab on his stomach and he was like,
they keep coming in and cut me in testimony and they're taking me to the doctor
today,
Ryan,
I think I got something.
I think I got a disease and that,
that cut.
I'm like,
what are you going to do?
He's like,
I got a plan.
So I talked to him later that day and I was like,
what did you do about that disease,
man?
He goes,
you know what I did with that scab?
I picked it off and throw it away.
He thought like the scab held the,
and you could just pick it off the flick it away and be like,
that shit's gone now Madison.
That's where he get that talk about it.
People,
it's not funny.
Melted and it's not.
Mental illness is obviously not funny,
but the shit he would do,
we would take him,
so it'd be me and my two brothers,
his daughter and two Tucson's on Christmas Eve,
we'd go over,
we take them a plate of food,
we'd hang out with them for a little while and shit and there'd be times where
he's like,
you guys got a joint,
like we shouldn't be smoking.
So we give them a joint and he smokes it and now we're driving back to my aunt's
in the city,
which is 12 minutes away.
We get back.
What are you all given him?
We Hebrew,
he would rat us out.
He's like,
Hey,
they came over,
gave him that food.
Thanks by the way.
They give you a big fat joint.
So then we would play it at why you listen to his crazy ass.
Nobody gave him like we all had to be able to say t
oh he would.
He,
he con he smokes.
He would come to my grandma's house when I live with her.
He'd sit in a chair and he smoked cigarettes like this and he doesn't pull it
any farther away than three by three inches from his mouth and not just down
done down,
done.
And he'll do,
he'll go through three pack.
My,
his mom died of breast cancer and she would say all the time,
I don't know how he even has a fucking throat left and I'm dying of cancer over
here and he is,
he's still alive.
Still alive.
Smoking cigarettes like that too.
Still Smoking cigarettes.
Like to chain a carton in three days.
What does a carton,
I don't even know.
20 packs.
That's roughly seven packs a day.
A day for,
for decades.
For decades.
Oh my God.
That is so crazy.
Now what,
do you remember what he was like before
schizophrenia?
I don't,
because when I was a kid he was already gone,
but my dad loved them and would bring them out to the house cause he was safe.
He was just crazy.
He would say shit and he'd be like,
don't you know,
don't give him a break.
Yeah,
don't vignettes.
Right.
Be Nice.
They'll give them a bug in Britain,
but my dad would tell me all the time,
he was a phenomenal athlete.
Like I said,
great at karate.
He had a black belt.
He was cross,
no,
just a sweat.
He tried to tell me.
So Highland town is the area where,
uh,
my aunt never is,
is the old Greek town in Baltimore.
It's not,
it's,
you know,
Greek as long gone in that neighborhood.
But that's where he grew up and he would try to tell me that Highland town was
the Haight Ashbury in Baltimore.
I was like,
get the fuck outta here at that garbage.
But he was doing acid,
you know,
early 11
and he dabble.
I think he said that early.
And then eventually after like into the college years,
the 20s he really fucking ramped it up.
And he was all mine
before that.
Yeah,
100% he made himself crazy story.
The common story is people that have a tendency to schizophrenia or there may
be,
they have a likelihood of developing it later in their life.
Acid trips,
mushroom trips,
heavy.
Psychedelics tend to bring out schizophrenia.
They tend to make it manifest.
So maybe he was ripe for it because there's,
there's no other mental illness in the family.
It's just him.
Just him.
Um,
yeah,
man.
I think especially when you're young,
you know,
I mean,
think about how many people have had horrible,
horrible acid trips.
Just taken way too much and tried to fight it and just been fucked up for days
and weeks and then you still feel slippery.
Like life feels weird.
Even after those trips,
I had a DMT trip one time that fucked me up for a couple weeks.
Like for a couple of weeks afterwards,
I'd be driving my car and to be thinking there's going to be a car,
it's going to launch itself off the fucking,
the,
the oncoming lane and fly right into me.
I was thinking,
I had this image that was going to be upside down in the,
the,
the car was going to hit the windshield flying upside down and down and just
slightly for weeks,
weeks,
weeks afterwards.
That's why I'm scared of that shit.
It's because,
okay.